gewaltig und
aufbau eines imperiums oder entstehung
einer neuen weltordnung des handels
[Musik]
das programm wird nicht von china
dominiert vielmehr arbeitet china mit
anderen ländern zusammen
denn tafel die sich aus china durch
zentralasien und europa dem nahen osten
afrika indien und südostasien ziel auf
dem land wie auf der sie durch völlig
unerschlossene wirtschaftsgebiet
pleiten sind in der infrastruktur immer
möglich
am ende wird das projekt china und seine
partner billionen dollar kosten
diese länder brauchen infrastruktur geld
wird der antrieb sein
[Musik]
hallo ich bin steven randall und zeige
ihnen wie die älteste bestehen der
zivilisation der welt die zukunft ihrer
wirtschaft gestalten wird waging
erschafft mit der neuen seidenstraße
eine neue dynastie
sie sind ein symbol des chinesischen
fortschritts so auch das tempo mit dem
das schienennetz ausgebaut wird die züge
sind über 300 km h schnell
für manche sind sie auch sinnbild der
ehrgeizigen neuen seidenstraße
entgegen häufiger irrtümer wird das
programm nicht von china dominiert
vielmehr arbeitet china mit anderen
ländern zusammen
es ist eine zusammenarbeit mit
internationalen institutionen und
entwicklungsbanken
leider wird dies von manchen
missverstanden als chinesisches programm
über das andere ausgenutzt und chinas
interessen geschützt werden soll
das entspricht überhaupt nicht den
tatsachen
china löst auf gemischte gefühle aus
chinas infrastrukturprojekte kommen gut
an die märkte brauchen dringend bessere
verkehrsmittel und straßen insbesondere
kleine und mittlere staaten wurde er
infrastrukturausbau schwierig ist
zeitgleich gibt es bedenken
oft hört man aus betroffenen ländern das
chinesische firmen stets den größten
vorteil daraus ziehen
in den kommenden zehn 15 jahren werden
weltweit etwa 90 millionen dollar in
infrastruktur investiert werden vor
allem in aufstrebenden märkten und
entwicklungsländern
die summe ist gewaltig aber doch nur ein
kleiner prozentsatz der weltweiten
infrastrukturausgaben und vielleicht
weniger als fünf prozent der
infrastrukturausgaben in asien
es ist ein sehr großes projekt aber man
sollte es in seinem kontext nicht
unnötig aufbauschen
[Musik]
im grunde genommen will china die alte
seidenstraße mit moderner infrastruktur
wieder berlin wirtschafts korridore
einrichten helfen verbinden und eine
seidenstraße zur sie einrichten die nach
china zurück führt in der praxis erweist
sich das als kompliziert
bei 86 ländern ist eher schwierig zu
sagen welche länder nicht zur neuen
seidenstraße gehören
zudem verlief die alte seidenstraße zur
sie damals westwärts durch
die zunehmende annäherung von china und
lateinamerika
könnte sie nun aber auch nach osten
verlaufen
oder nach afrika im südwesten
es ist also ein projekt für regionale
und globale integration
anfangs ging es um infrastruktur dar um
überschüssiges material zu nutzen doch
mittlerweile ist es so viel mehr es
entsteht ein ganzes ökosystem durch das
projekt
viele chinesische firmen staatlich wie
privat sind beteiligt und wollen sich
beteiligen nicht nur wegen der
seidenstraße sondern weil es eine
lukrative chance
sie wachsen durch die hohen
infrastrukturausgaben
der politische aspekt ist ganz anders
als vor fünf jahren
die neue seidenstraße steht noch am
anfang
sie ist noch in der planungsphase
es gibt schon einige projekte in
zentralasien wie die straße nach quader
in pakistan aber sie steht noch am
anfang
70 aber bereits die grundlegende idee
die welt näher an ost asien und
insbesondere china heranzuführen
die chinesische führung leides ernst das
projekt wurde in der verfassung der
kommunistischen partei verankert
auf gedeih und verderb wird das projekt
als schätzing kings erbe in die
geschichte eingehen
präsident jean ping hat klar und
deutlich gesagt wir werden keinen garten
in unserem hinterhof bauen
wir wollen einen wunderschönen garten
voller wunderschöner blumen bauen den
alle länder der welt genießen können
die neue seidenstraße ist ein wichtiger
schlüssel der strategie chinas
unterschieden
es geht um die geschichte vom aufstieg
chinas und das tatsächliche ausmaß von
chinas wirtschaft und handelsmacht
verschiedene ist nun wirtschaftlich fast
gleichauf mit den usa
je nachdem wie man es misst sogar größer
denn es betreibt vielmehr handelt als
die usa die neue seidenstraße passt zur
erzielung vom aufstieg chinas und von
der offenheit chinas in china sagen wir
wer hohe ziele verfehlt erreicht immer
noch hohe ergebnisse wer mittlere ziele
verfehlt erzählt schwache ergebnisse
china ist sehr ehrgeizig aber der
ehrgeiz dient dem wohle der ganzen welt
zehn länder machen fast 70 prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung der neuen
seidenstraße aus chinesische firmen habe
und zwar manche erfolgreichen verträge
abgeschlossen müssen sich aber anpassen
um sich gegen koreanische japanische
amerikanische europäische oder lokale
firmen zu behaupten seien sie noch ein
türkisch oder indisch sie müssen mit
ihnen zusammenarbeiten
wenn in südostasien pakistan kasachstan
oder afrika infrastruktur gebaut wird
sollte zuallererst das jeweilige land
die infrastruktur gestalten
das muss bei der umsetzung der idee
unbedingt beachtet werden
wenn china einfach diktiert wie die
infrastruktur auszusehen habe scheitert
das projekt
neue wege straßen schienen pipelines und
häfen china super highway nimmt gestalt
an und bringt chinesische ware in alle
welt und alle welt wiederum nach china
als nächstes werden wir die risiken
neuer unbekannter handelswege hat
[Musik]
eine herausforderung bei der umsetzung
der neuen seidenstraße wird für china
die finanzierung sein es werden kosten
zwischen 4 und 8 billionen dollar
erwartet die große frage ist jedoch wie
china im umgang mit riskanten wenig
kreditwürdigen ländern sein geld
verwalten wird
von den etwa 70 starken die china als
partner auf zählt gelten 27 als nicht
kreditwürdig
für 14 weitere wie zum beispiel
afghanistan iran und syrien gibt es
nicht mal eine bewertung
pleiten sind bei infrastrukturprojekten
am anfang immer möglich darum ist die
richtige finanzierung zur rechten zeit
am rechten ort in ausreichender menge so
entscheidend hier wollen multilaterale
banken unterstützen sie bringen sich im
frühen hochriskanten stadium ein und
mildern das risiko
unser vorgehen ist klar die bank ist
inklusive
wir zwingen niemanden böswillig diese
bank auf denn es ist letztlich die
entscheidung souveräner regierungen
die tür steht offen wir laden sie ein
wehr bei treten und mit anderen
mitgliedern zusammen arbeiten will ist
uns willkommen
jede regierung hat dabei ihre eigenen
vorstellungen
so viele geschäfte zwischen regierungen
könnten ein problem sein aber die neue
seidenstraße entwickelt sich weiter und
wir sehen zunehmend profit gesteuerte
geschäfte nicht nur zwischenstaatlichen
sondern privaten unternehmen
gerade chinas technologiefirmen drängen
in die märkte der seidenstraße um mark
gesteuerte chancen zu nutzen
welche rolle sollten geschäftsbanken
dabei spielen auch sie wollen risiken
vermeiden werden aber viele uns von der
politik beeinflusst
die rolle der geschäftsbanken ist sehr
wichtig insbesondere der internationalen
geschäftsbanken
denn sie durchleuchten die projekte
wählen sie gewissenhaft aus und
finanzieren sie letztendlich
chinesische behörden wissen das und ich
höre immer wieder dieselben argumente
wir brauchen die mitarbeit der
internationalen geschäftsbanken wir
werden nicht alle projekte finanzieren
und wir wollen keine viele investitionen
sondern sinnvolle projekte
transparenz und verantwortungsvolle
staatsführung sind herausforderungen für
die neue seidenstraße
der neu gewählte premierminister von
malaysia hat einige der verträge seines
vorgängers aufgehoben und in sri lanka
truth ein schuldenausfall das projekt
vom kurs abzubringen
sie lanka ist ein gutes beispiel
china hat hier einen hafen finanziert
der sich als nicht wirtschaftlich
erwiesen hat weshalb china übernommen
hat das werden wir in kleinen
anfälligeren ländern öfter beobachten
infrastruktur klingt erstmal teuer aber
wenn die geschäfte dann ausbleiben
bringt das auch nichts
der hafen von hamburg wurde errichtet
ohne vorher wirtschaftlichkeit studien
durchzuführen
so geriet die regierung sri lankas in
die schuldenfalle und musste den hafen
für neun jahre in china vermieten
einschließlich eines gewaltigen
sechseinhalb quadratkilometer großen
gebietes um den hafen herum
für indien den größten kritiker der
neuen seidenstraße geht es um die
nationale sicherheit
chinas mammut projekt erstreckt sich
durch ganz pakistan bis zur hafenstadt
war da am indischen ozean
in bezug auf die seidenstraße zur see
muss man bedenken dass china
mittlerweile die kontrolle oder eine
anteilsmehrheit über 75 häfen in 35
ländern erlangt hat
es ist klar dass sie dabei sicherlich
nicht nur kommerzielle interessen
verfolgen
je näher man an china ist desto nervöser
sind die reaktionen das sieht man zb in
indien manche asien länder sind besorgt
wegen der strategischen komponente
china gibt kein deutscher und lars viel
geld kaufte sich quasi deren
freundschaft
diese wiederum geben china ein veto in
asien da das bündnis über einstimmigkeit
funktioniert in bezug auf das
südchinesische meer kann china somit auf
die unterstützung von laos und
kambodscha bauen damit asian nicht gegen
die interessen chinas handelt
china baut seine präsenz im indischen
ozean rapide aus
es ist klar dass china sich als
großmacht sowie etablieren wir streiten
nicht darüber
dennoch hat es auch für uns folgen
aufsteigenden mächte wie china zwingen
benachbarte länder wie indien oder
jemals vorherrschen der
wirtschaftsmächte wie die usa dazu ihre
rolle zu überdenken
sie sind besorgt wegen der stärke chinas
und der in meinen augen durchaus
berechtigten engeren anbindung chinas an
den rest der welt
es geht um viel mehr als nur handelswege
entlang der alten seidenstraße
globalisierung vernetzungen moderne
transportmittel und finanzen
die finanzierung dieser projekte ist
noch ungewiss
auch in ländern wie pakistan sind die
details der finanzierung dieser
geschäfte noch unklar
es gibt bedenken dass die lokalen
regierungen zu viel für chinesische
verträge bezahlen
die ersten chinesischen darlehen der
letzten jahre gingen an länder ohne
stabile regierung wie venezuela sondern
angola iran pakistan
länder die durchaus schulden probleme
bekommen könnten aber auch länder wie
indonesien südafrika und ost
afrikanische länder gehören zu den
gläubigern
china hat bessere und schlechtere
klienten und in den besser verwalten
ländern sind durchaus erfolge zu
erwarten
man fokussiert sich oft auf geschäfte
von vor fünf jahren die gerade fertig
werden die helfen und schienennetze
wenn man sich aber tief greifend mit
diesen projekten befasst und die
aktuellen geschäfte betrachtet
unterscheiden sie sich überhaupt nicht
von den plänen anderer großer länder
dieser im bezug auf die nächsten jahre
besonders aufregende und
vielversprechende aspekt wird oft
übersehen
für hafenbetreiber wie in hongkong sind
die chancen enorm
es werden handels zuwächse und bis zu
zweieinhalb millionen dollar in zehn
jahren erwartet als nächstes erfahren
wir die perspektive von maersk und apm
terminals zur neuen seidenstraße
[Musik]
sind sie an der ältesten der vier großen
alten hauptstädte chinas heimat der han
dynastie und der terrakotta armee am
östlichen ende der alten seidenstraße
[Musik]
im muslimischen viertel schienen kann
man einen blick in die vergangenheit
werfen
viele hier sind nachfahren arabische
händler die monatelang auf der
seidenstraße nach china reiste
dass china als größte handelsnationen
den welthandel fördern will überrascht
wenig
die neue seidenstraße dient ganz
offensichtlich auch dem ziel das
handelsvolumen um 2,5 millionen dollar
in zehn jahren zu erhöhen
einige projekte sind für uns als
logistikanbieter sehr reizvoll
mehr handelsvolumen bedeutet mehr fracht
für unsere schiffe mehr umsatz in den
häfen mehr güter in den lagerhäusern
wo sehen sie in der infrastruktur die
größten lücken
man muss die vernetzung weiter ausbauen
die forschung zeigt dass bessere
vernetzung der transportwege die kosten
des handels verringert wodurch der
handel wächst
eine 10 prozentige verbesserung der
vernetzung senkt die kosten um drei
prozent und erhöht das volumen um 5 bis
9 prozent
wir sehen eine direkte verbindung dieser
zwei faktoren
ibm tamina ist die container terminal
sparte von maersk betreibt 78 häfen in
58 ländern
viele entlang der alten seidenstraße
einige unserer fortgeschritteneren
projekte fallen in den bereich der neuen
seidenstraße
im italienischen val d'or richten wir
gemeinsam mit cosco und der qingdao port
group ein neues containerterminal
auch in afrika richten wir gemeinsam mit
chinesischen firmen helfen wenn es in
unser beider interesse liegt chance für
die zusammenarbeit bieten sich also
nicht nur in asien sondern entlang der
gesamten neuen seidenstraße
was sollte in den ersten jahren der
neuen seidenstraße unser hauptaugenmerk
sein
wir würden uns verbesserungen bei der
transparenz erhoffen
oft erfahren wir erst von projekten wenn
die beteiligten sich bereits geeinigt
haben
hier würden sich internationale firmen
gerne mehr einbringen
das können wir auch bei der eu
beobachten auch dort gilt die
verbesserung der transparenz als
schlüsselkomponente für den
langfristigen erfolg der neuen
seidenstraße
es gibt viele hindernisse aber auf
ungeahnte möglichkeiten
wer wird letztendlich am meisten von den
millionen ausgaben für die neue
seidenstraße profitieren
es geht zunehmend um stabilere länder
und allgemeine infrastruktur finanzieren
länder wie brasilien südafrika und
ostafrika mit großen bedarf an
infrastruktur
sie sehen darin gewaltiges potenzial die
vorstellung der größten chinesischen
infrastruktur verschwörung ist einfach
unrealistisch
letztendliches geld die treibende kraft
wenn chinesische firmen zb
fortschrittliche schienenverkehrs
projekte in indien errichten können und
indische firmen das als chance
wahrnehmen mit einer partnerschaft geld
zu verdienen werden sie es tun
geld wird weiterhin die treibende kraft
sein die
nachbarländer chinas und die länder auf
dem weg von china nach europa werden als
erste profitieren
zentralasien und südostasien
ich hoffe jedoch dass die verbindung
nach südasien insbesondere nach indien
gestärkt wird denn das indische
chinesische verhältnis ist wohl das
bedeutendste der welt
außerdem hoffe ich dass afrika stark
davon profitieren kann um zu den großen
wachstumsmärkten in asien aufzuschließen
präsidentin betonte in seiner
monumentalen deklaration beim ersten
treffen zu dem thema die verbindungen
der neuen seidenstraßen zu bereits
bestehenden initiativen
die von anderen ländern hervor gebracht
wurden
daher unterstützt die asiatische
infrastruktur investmentbank die
initiative
wenn projekte an uns herangetragen
werden müssen sie natürlich unseren
standards entsprechen
unsere drei grundlegenden standards sind
finanzielle nachhaltigkeit
umweltschutz und der schutz der
interessen der bevölkerung vor ort
der mitte des 15 jahrhunderts begann
aufgrund des effizienteren handels zur
see sowie streitigkeiten zwischen
teilnehmerstaaten der zerfall der
seidenstraße zu der zeit wurde auch die
verbotene stadt hinterm ihr fertig
gestellt die für die folgenden 500 jahre
den chinesischen kaiser bewerber an
sollte die wiederbelebung der
seidenstraße bezeugt chinas erneuten
aufstieg als globale handelsmacht ich
bin steven ende vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit